[MUSIC PLAYING]
WESLEY CHUN: Hi, and welcome to
"Serverless Migration Station."
I'm Wesley from Google, joined
by Martin to familiarize you
with modernizing
your apps on one
of our serverless
compute platforms.
This time, our
little friend Porter
will take us on the final leg
of our migration to Cloud Tasks,
doing a mixture of
optional migrations.
MARTIN OMANDER: More
optional migrations, Wes?
Why are we even making
this video, then?
WESLEY CHUN: Well, when
modernizing your apps,
there are going to
be some steps which
are less critical than others.
But they may be necessary
at some point, so we're here
to show our friends
out there how
to do them when the time comes.
MARTIN OMANDER: I
suppose you're right.
How many of these optional
migrations are we looking at
and what are they?
WESLEY CHUN: Aha.
Glad you're a good sport.
We're doing three
migrations today,
all optional but recommended.
First, we're porting
from Python 2 to 3.
You probably should
move to Python 3,
since Python 2 has
been sunset and that's
where the community
has moved to, right?
Honestly, this app is already
compatible with both Python 2
and 3, so there's really not
much work to be done here.
Next, moving to Cloud Tasks
is also pretty much a no-op--
meaning you don't really
need to change anything
beyond the version numbers.
However, this may be
different in future versions.
For now, it suffices to say
that development on Cloud Tasks
has froze for Python 2.
Hence why the client
library is on version 1,
whereas Python 3's
is on version 2.
Finally, we know
from modules 2 and 3
that Cloud NDB is just a
migration tool for Python 2 App
Engine developers.
From modules 6 and 10, we
know that Cloud Firestore
is the latest NoSQL database
solution from Google Cloud.
By going straight there, we
get to jump over the Cloud
Datastore migration.
Moving directly
to Firestore does
require a completely
different project,
so this endeavor is
optional, but more
like building a prototype to
see what these migrations entail
and for you to consider before
doing these to your own apps.
MARTIN OMANDER: OK,
those all make sense.
It's been a while since I've
done one of these migrations.
Before we do the
migration today,
can I get a quick review
of how we got here?
WESLEY CHUN: Yep.
Sure, Martin.
Previously in module 8, we
migrated from App Engine task
queues to Cloud Tasks.
Because migrating
to Cloud Firestore
requires a brand new project,
you should get more details
from module 6.
Links to the videos and codelabs
are below so you can catch up,
as we're going to pick up
where module 8 left off
and merge in part of
that module 6 migration.
MARTIN OMANDER:
Sounds good, Wes.
You know I'm here to
learn all about the ways
to modernize my apps and get
hands-on experience doing so.
Can you put me to code,
as well as the codelab,
so I can do this migration on
my own time after watching you?
WESLEY CHUN: Of course, Martin.
Same drill as before
for all of you.
Use your module 8
solution or clone the repo
or download the zip file
if you don't have it.
We'll start with
the module 8 code
and finish with what's in
the module 9 repo folder.
Links to the repo and codelab
are down below, so pause here
if you need to go get anything.
Ready?
Let's dive into
these migrations.
Since we're doing several
migrations with a bunch of code
changes, you have
to confirm you're
starting with the working module
8 code, whether yours or ours.
If you're on Python 2,
double-check your lib folder
or blow it away and run
the pip install command
to reinstall those third-party
packages into the lib folder.
Then use gcloud app deploy
and confirm your App Engine
app outputs the same most
recent visit list and possibly
older visits to delete
with a push task.
Now, if things look good,
copy the entire folder,
as we're going to make
major changes to it,
as we will deploy to a
completely different project.
First up, app.yaml,
where modern App Engine
doesn't require much.
For simple apps like this
one, the most critical part
is switching from Python
2 to 3, and as a result,
moving from the first generation
to second-generation service.
One big change is
that web frameworks
must do their own routing.
This means that all app
handlers have to switch to auto.
But if everything
is auto, you really
don't need them
at all, especially
since the framework does it.
So yes, you can remove all app
handlers, like what we did.
But if you've got static
files, leave them here,
because that does not go
through the framework.
Next, the section 4 built-in
third party libraries
is no longer needed.
They now go into
requirements.txt.
Similarly, there's no more
copying or self-bundling
of non-built-in libraries.
You just put them into
requirements.txt and that's it.
This is covered in a bit more
detail in the module 2 video,
linked below.
For our simple
app, the net result
is that you can delete all lines
except for the runtime, where
we're sending it
to python38 here.
Since all third-party management
is in requirements.txt,
that means no more
appengine_config file,
so delete that, too.
For requirements.txt, we know
that all third-party packages
go in here now.
Version numbers do need a
bump, because every library
has a final version
that works on Python 2.
For us, this was
Cloud Tasks 1.5.
Today, the version
for Python 3 is 2.3,
but that too will change.
Similarly, we're switching from
Cloud NDB to Cloud Firestore,
so this line has to
be completely swapped.
In Python 2, we self-bundled
third-party libraries with pip
install.
But in Python 3, don't do that.
Seriously, Google
takes care of this
when deploying so you don't
have to lift a finger.
Are we liking Python 3 yet?
Anyway, that's it
for the config files.
Let's turn to the real
work, and that's in main.py.
At the top, there
are two changes.
One is that logging
in Python 3 is easier.
You don't need to use Python
logging, just print to stdout.
So remove that import.
Next, we're switching from
Cloud NDB to Cloud Firestore,
so swap that client
library import.
Finally, instantiate
the correct API clients.
Next, all of the constants
for task queues stay the same,
but we have to add a new one.
The QUEUE_PATH variable is
the fully-qualified queue path
name.
One difference between
App Engine task queues
and Cloud Tasks we didn't
cover last time in module 8
is that when using App
Engine push queues,
the default queue
was automatically
created by App Engine.
But that's not the case
with Cloud Tasks, which
is independent of App Engine.
With Cloud Tasks, you need to
create all of your push queues,
including the default
queue if you want one.
And to do so, you need the path
name up to, but not including,
the queue name.
So that's what the
PATH_PREFIX is.
For store_visit(), the changes
you see are the differences
between Cloud NDB
and Cloud Firestore.
Cloud Firestore doesn't
have a data model,
nor does it require context
managers and with statements.
In NDB, we refer to data records
as entities of a certain kind,
while Firestore has documents
belonging to collections.
Regardless of all this, know
that store_visit() has one job.
It creates a new data record
with the connecting client IP,
as well as their web
client or user agent.
One last note.
NDB automatically
adds a timestamp
when an object is created,
but it must be done explicitly
in Firestore.
Since App Engine task queues
create a default queue
by default, we didn't
need a function like
_create_queue_if() in
our module 8 main.py.
Before creating a
task, this function
is used to check if
we need to create
the queue, which is only done
if it doesn't already exist.
Next is fetch_visits().
At the top, querying for
the most recent visits
has to change from Cloud
NDB to Cloud Firestore.
Again, the functionality
is identical.
The differences are
just between how
NDB does it versus Firestore.
For the next section,
fortunately, Cloud Tasks
doesn't change between version
1 and version 2 of the client
library, so no real
updates to your code
are needed as to how
the task is created.
Now the logging call
has to change to a print
and we have to add that check
to make sure the queue exists
before adding the task.
You may ask why we
didn't do this before
with Cloud Tasks in module 8.
And again, it's because the
module 7 code used App Engine
task queues, where the default
queue was automatically
created.
Now, it wasn't
until this app where
we had to use Cloud Firestore,
requiring us to create
a completely brand new project,
that we discovered that we had
to make our own default queue.
Let's skip over this new
function, _delete_docs(),
for just a moment and dive
into the trim() task handler.
We saw just a moment ago from
fetch_visits() how querying is
identical, but NDB and Firestore
do it slightly differently.
The same applies to this
query, looking for visits older
than the oldest one shown.
One subtle difference is that
NDB has convenient batching,
like a keys-only query since I
don't need to look at the data,
plus a delete multi-function
for batch delete.
In Firestore, you would issue
a regular query, then loop
through and delete them one at
a time or use a batch delete.
Since I want to log all
the objects deleted,
I moved the deletion
loop into _delete_docs,
a generator that yields the ID
for each document deleted so I
can count how many were deleted
and log that back in trim().
Otherwise, I logged that
there weren't any old records
to delete.
The main GET handler
doesn't change at all,
so we're skipping that.
So overall, that
was probably one
of the more intense migrations
so far in this series
if you look at how
much code was deleted,
updated, or new code was added.
Simple migrations are
great for teaching,
but generally not as realistic.
So the goal was to try
and make it more lifelike.
We actually forgot
one last migration
of porting this app
from Python 2 to 3.
But don't worry, I'm
not going to keep
this video running too long.
I deliberately crafted
all of the sample
apps to run on both Python 2
and 3 without any modifications
or compatibility libraries,
so the porting part
is already done.
Now that everyone's on Python 3,
you've got no more pip install,
so just run gcloud app
deploy to confirm it
works as advertised,
making sure that you
change to your new
project before doing so.
Because we're doing more
migrations in this module,
the chances of doing
something wrong
is higher, so let the logs
help you or you can check out
our solution in the
module 9 repo folder
to compare your
answers with ours.
All right.
Let's go back to the
main presentation.
MARTIN OMANDER: Wow, lots of
different migrations and things
to consider.
If I wanted to get more
information about migrating
my App Engine app from Python
2 to 3, where should I look?
WESLEY CHUN: Yeah.
The best place is
the Python 2 to 3
App Engine migration guide.
It links to all the
individual pages
for migrating to Cloud
Datastore, Cloud Tasks, and all
the other standalone services.
MARTIN OMANDER: OK.
And same for Cloud NDB
and Cloud Firestore?
I'd like to review both to get
a better idea of the differences
between them.
Do you have any links for them?
WESLEY CHUN: Yep, sure thing.
While we don't have a
formal Cloud NDB product
page, nor an NDB to
Firestore migration guide,
your best resources are
the client library docs
for both, as well as the
general Cloud Firestore docs.
MARTIN OMANDER: Ah.
Yeah, those look really useful.
Also, now that we're checking
for and creating our own task
queues, I need to
read up on those?
WESLEY CHUN: Gotcha.
Well, all the links mentioned
here, plus the Cloud Task
client library and general docs,
are down below for your reading
pleasure.
MARTIN OMANDER: Great.
Thanks for those, Wes.
Are we doing any more
task queue migrations?
WESLEY CHUN: Nope.
Well, this is the last of
the task queue miniseries.
Summarizing today's adventure,
we ported our app from Python 2
to 3.
We moved from Cloud
NDB to Cloud Firestore,
combining modules 3 and 6.
And we revved up to the latest
Cloud Tasks client library,
including adding new code
to create the default
queue, something we didn't
need before since we were still
running on our original project
where the App Engine task
queues system automatically
created that default queue.
MARTIN OMANDER: Cool.
What other migrations should I
consider for my App Engine app?
WESLEY CHUN: Well,
since we've already
done Cloud NDB, Cloud
Datastore, and Firestore,
you're done with all
the database stuff.
Now if you're thinking about
containerizing your App Engine
apps to run on Cloud Run, well,
check out modules 4 and 5.
Finally, if you've
got a tiny app that's
just one function
or a giant app you
want to break up
into microservices,
those sound like really good
use cases for Cloud Functions,
and that migration is
covered in module 11.
There are other
migrations coming,
so look out for blog
posts, as well as checking
the repo from time to time
for more migration content.
MARTIN OMANDER: Thanks, Wes.
I'll check those out.
WESLEY CHUN: And
thank all of you
for sticking with us for all
these different migrations.
This is Wesley, on behalf
of Martin and Porter,
and we'll see you at the
next "Migration Station"
or on another "Serverless
Expedition" soon.
[MUSIC PLAYING]